Muslim yes I am
brother welcome to the panel thank
you um
so pretty much I like to say the least
is you know every time I look at your
channel right it's always about Islam
why is it always that you're always
attacking this Islam you know well
that's a good question the reason why I
talk a lot about Islam is because Islam
talks a lot about Christianity and gets
a lot of things wrong about Jesus about
the prophets and so there's a lot of
misconception spread in the Islamic
community and uh I feel called by God to
reach these people I can understand that
but you know when I look at you know how
Muslims react to other Christians
they're not always coming out attacking
Christians you know well then your head
has probably been under a rock man
because uh that's all the daag gandis do
they hold entire live streams attacking
Paul attacking the Bible um attacking
the deity of Christ and who he is and
all kinds of stuff so if you're saying
that you don't see Muslims do this
either you're lying or maybe you just
are new to the internet and maybe you
just got a computer today no no it's not
that at all it's like just based on my
experience I'm not always on like these
type of channels doing all this stuff
you know so I'm just pretty much asking
but to say but to say the least what do
you mean when you say no muslim can
defend Islam like when we look at our
different philosophical views based on
what you guys believe and what we
believe you know I like to look at it
from a very simple concept as like in
order for God to be God what attributes
do he have to have so when we look at it
from that perspective we say that God is
all knowing allseeing all hearing and in
order for him to be all knowing all
seeing and all hearing he has to have
those attributes at all times because
the second he loses those attributes or
limits it then that that that defeats
the purpose of him being God which can
also conclude that he can't also be
human like you understand my stance on
that
yeah so I I would say that well going
with that stance then you would have to
go against Allah Jason Cas was funny he
says because Islam's low hanging through
uh Allah in the Quran is shown to be
dependent he's shown that he um would
need help to do certain things he
depends on things outside of himself to
do things so with that logic you would
have to you would have to reject Allah
of the not not necessarily I mean what
would what would you say that is well uh
he can't have a son unless he has a
mate I think well based on I think I'm
very familiar with that verse I think
based on that verse it's not saying it
out of incapability it's just saying it
through like the human perspective of
how we understand it um he's higher than
that he wouldn't actually do that
because he's above he doesn't say that
he doesn't say he's higher than that or
above it he says how can he he says how
can he have a son when he has no mate So
it's talking about his capability
but that but then you're just limiting
him by saying that but that that doesn't
really make sense wait say that again
say that again it's doing what by saying
that no hold on
bro I don't know you no come on G listen
relax relax you hit it right on the nail
by saying that it's doing what to Allah
okay look look look I don't know the the
Arabic koks behind this of just said
that just say it again it's doing what
okay he's not he's probably saying it
from a different perspective brother
brother stop come on you said the word
it started with an L when he when when
you phrase it like that it's doing work
to him it's doing what like I said I
don't I don't think it's out of
incapability he's saying that that's
that's not what I asked you Gabe come on
Gabe don't make me rewind the tape I'll
rewind it to get it out of your I know I
know what I said all right I did say
that I didn't intentionally mean to say
that huh say it one last time that
phrase when you say how can he have a
son when he has no mate that phrase is
doing what to him you said it starts
with an L it's doing
what I don't remember what I said all
right so hold on I got you brother you
don't got to Rive nothing BR listen yeah
I'm trying to understand look bro I
don't want to it's look I'm talking
about attributes bro I'm only talking
about attributes I'm here I am here for
you I am here for God is one he's not
he's not equal to anything in far as
another human being that's that's that's
right but hold on a second let's go
ahead
whoops what just happened okay let's go
here and let's see what you actually
said because we have to know we're going
my god brother it's okay man it's all
right okay so let's get it here let's
see actually let's give him big screen
all right so hold on everybody listen
let's see I don't remember what I said
all right so hold on oh hold on I muted
it you
understand I don't doing what he has no
mate say it one last time all I did
sayab don't make me saying he's probably
saying it from a different say it again
it right by saying that but that that
doesn't really make
sense but that but then you're just
limiting him by saying that but that
that doesn't really make sense say that
again that but then you're just limiting
him by saying that yeah I got it bro I
got it I accidentally I said it without
thinking bro that's not bad limiting him
by saying that but that so it's doing
what listen I don't think he's doing it
out of incapability all right I don't
know the Tere behind wait what is that
phrase what does that phrase do to Allah
you said it there what does that phrase
do to Allah by saying that would defeat
his nature I'm trying to tell you that
would defeat his nature that was my
mistake I didn't mean to say it defeats
his nature because his nature is
supposed to be all powerful correct yet
he's not all powerful enough to have a
son without a mate but he's higher he's
trying to say he's higher than that he
wouldn't do that you know we're not
talking about what he would do we
understand having a son or having a mate
is beneath him he wouldn't do that but
can he is the
question I mean God can do as he Wills
but like I said and if he were to do
that that would pretty much defeat his
nature why would he need to he can have
a
son only if he had a mate to have a son
with
right and
necessarily brother I
mean be as it is like he can see you're
you're right Kun be and is if he wills
it he says b and boom he could have a
son supposedly theoretically except you
have where the Quran tells you how can
he have a son when he doesn't have a
mate therefore limiting him making him
not all powerful and dependent so then
that would be the same thing for your
religion bro no in My Religion lied let
me tell you in my religion God doesn't
rely on anything outside of himself in
order to have a son Jesus is the
begotten son of the father straight from
the father's Essence he the father
didn't need a companion in order to have
a son and have Jesus no by God's Own
very essence his own nature he generates
and begets Jesus the son eternally he
didn't need a mate but Allah does so
which God is all
powerful I would still say Allah because
God because God doesn't have a he is one
in the
essence know but you what you're pretty
much saying is that like if you were to
have a son that would be limiting him
that's what you're saying why are you
making that phas bro
no I'm not playing with you I'm being
serious man it's illogical to say God is
a human being based on those attributes
because humans
are would you agree that it's illogical
to suggest that Allah would need a
maiden to in order to have a son that's
illogical right yes so the quran's
illogical no I wouldn't I mean I
wouldn't listen bro the quran's
illogical talk I'll talk about for your
stance bro because there's
no my stance is your stance I remember I
agreed with you I followed you that God
has particular attributes right that
make him God right okay and to fail in
any of these attributes or
characteristics that wouldn't be God
being all powerful and not being limited
being self-sufficient these are some of
the things you said which I agree with
which is why I reject Allah as God
because he he's not self-sufficient he's
dependent on other things this was one
of the examples I mean being
self-sufficient is like you don't rely
on food or rely on water like immortal
being self-sufficient means that you
rely on your own self okay right you
don't need anything outside of yourself
for anything you're
self-sufficient okay I agree so but
Allah he needs a mate something outside
of himself in order to have a son if he
wanted to do that so therefore he's not
that's the different that's the
different doctrines that we have between
each other you know what I'm saying
that's why we don't agree on those two
things agree on what the two things that
um God would never have a son because
he's higher than that like we
established but you believe that he
would have a son that's not what we're
arguing though we're not for forget the
wood he parted first let let me even
grant you that he would never do that
okay the fact that he could or could not
do it that's what makes or
breaks would he have a son you know if
he would he would if he wouldn't he
wouldn't that doesn't take away from him
being self-sufficient or being God what
takes it away is whether he can or not
or if he would need help to do so or not
you get what I'm
saying but then can we also look at the
The Stance of like can God make a rock
so heavy that he can't lift no that's
contradictory that within itself he
would never yeah but he wouldn't he
would never do that because that no the
answer is that he can't do that because
God can't contradict himself that would
actually be a a he would never that's
what I'm I'm trying to say he would
never make a rock so happy that he can
could
he
uh no I agree no the answer is no cuz
God can't contradict himself right he
can't contradict himself however him
having a son that's has nothing to do
with contradicting himself so even your
Quran says that he could have a son if
he wanted to that's 394 he could have a
son if he wanted to he would choose
something from his creation
however he would need a mate to do it
because I haven't read the entirety of
the Quran I'm gonna look into that so I
can I'm G to come back up here again
soon fair enough you you're you're more
than welcome Gabe I I liked you man this
was uh this was good come come back on
the subject we could talk or we could
talk about other things as well but um
but yeah come back and we'll we'll
finish this is that cool yeah cool bro
thank you Avery I appreciate that take
care man